ja das war ein krasses iaa oder ich weiß
dass ich letztes jahr genau dieses video
auch genauso angefangen habe aber 2020
war doch noch mal ne nummer krasser für
wahrscheinlich alle von uns herzlich
willkommen zu dem jahresrückblick viel
2020 werde in diesem video zurückschauen
auf unser selbstversorger ja und dann
mal beurteilen wie wir uns so geschlagen
haben was richtig gut gelaufen ist und
was so richtig in die hose gegangen ist
ich fange mit den guten sachen an ich
denke dass ein positiverer einstieg und
dann werde ich euch noch ein paar
schauer geschichten erzählen von den
sachen die dieses jahr so richtig
richtig schief gegangen sind als wir
unseren kanal noch nicht kennt ich bin
marie und ich versuche so viel wie
möglich von dem was wir essen selber zu
erzeugen also ich war das gemüse fast
komplett für meine familie an genauso
wie das obst wir haben außerdem hühner
für aja und ziegen für fleisch und milch
das ist eigentlich so der umfang in dem
sich unsere selbstversorgung bewegt
machen das vor allem weil wieder mega
viel spaß daran haben und weil es super
lecker ist wenn man richtig gutes essen
auf dem tisch hat wo man weiß wo das
herkommt was wir nicht machen ist zum
größten teil getreide und ölfrüchte und
schokolade und so was können wir
natürlich auch nicht selber anbauen also
es nicht so als würden wir gar nichts
mehr einkaufen
aber wir versuchen eben schon einen
großen batzen von dem was bei uns auf
dem tisch gelandet selber zu erzeugen
ich frage mal mit der sache an auf die
am meisten stolz bin dieses jahr
ich habe euch ja mal anfang des jahres
erzählt dass ich gerne hart mais anbauen
möchte und das habe ich gemacht und das
hat richtig richtig richtig gut
funktioniert wir haben da jetzt auch
schon brot raus gebacken also wir haben
zwei verschiedene hart meist sorten
angebaut also kein zucker mais und ein
so richtiger back meist eine sorte ist
für brot und für pfannkuchen geeignet
dafür popcorn und ein
sollte es für polenta geeignet ich finde
es richtig cool dass wir unsere
selbstversorgung so mein getreide
ergänzt haben wir es eh schon viel meist
er hat vorher gekauft haben in unserem
brot und da jetzt ohne das ist wirklich
großartig aufwändig war richtig viel
mais angebaut
ich habe ja schon mal ein video darüber
gemacht wo ich archive unseren tollen
mainz vorgeführt habe und das ist etwas
was mich richtig stolz macht und was ich
auch erstaunlich cool finde weil wir
haben denen auf unserem acker angebaut
und ihr wisst ja dass wir auf unserem
acker ja vielleicht alle paar monate mal
vorbeischauen weil der weiter weg ist
und wieder ja einfach darauf vertrauen
müssen dass alles gut wächst und ich
habe den einmal gesät dann war ich
einmal darum ihn zu mulchen und zu
düngen und dann war ich erst wieder zur
ernte da und ich hatte keine ahnung was
mich da erwartet und dann so was also
wir hatten quasi nur perfekte richtig
gut bestäubte super große und
wunderschöne maiskolben und das war der
hammer
also da ich bin total angefasst von mais
ich dachte immer irgendwie meist eine
unsympathische pflanze weil man die vor
allem von der monokultur kennt aber es
ist einfach eine ganz alte kulturpflanze
die der menschheit schon so viel gutes
geleistet hat und die in ganz vielen
kulturen total wichtig ist und ich werde
auf jeden fall nächstes jahr neue
maissorten ausprobieren und da noch
mehrmals anbauen und bin total angelegt
davon also das war richtig richtig
richtig cool was auch total gut gelaufen
ist dieses jahr waren die tomaten ich
verlinke euch mal die tomaten playlist
ich habe ganz viele tomatenanbau tipp
videos dieses jahr gemacht die sind ja
auch voll gut bei euch angekommen das
freut mich richtig an
ich verlege ich euch mal da oben und
unten in der video beschreibung wenn ihr
euch schon mal für nächstes jahr fit
machen wollt das sind richtig coole
tipps dabei um richtig die ernte
einzufahren und das hat diese ist ja bei
uns extrem gut geklappt so gut dass ich
irgendwann überhaupt nicht mehr
hinterhergekommen bin mit dem ernten
wir hatten schon soviel eingekocht und
immer noch so viele tomaten dranhängen
dass wir ehrlich gesagt ein paar
vergammelt sind am ende war ich einfach
keine tomaten mehr sehen konnte das war
ein bisschen schade ich habe schon
versucht welche zu verschenken und so
weiter aber irgendwann war es einfach zu
viel also nächstes jahr weniger
tomatenpflanzen aber ich bin total
begeistert davon wie gut das geklappt
hat dann habe ich mir eine ganze menge
37 gekauft ich hasse shoppen aber siegen
shoppen ich glaube ich bin jede woche
auf ebay kleinanzeigen unterwegs und
gucke ob ich da irgendwelche tollen
neuen ziegen die entdecker auf jeden
fall habe ich von einer rassel von der
ich unbedingt schon ganz lange zeit
haben wollte endlich zwei tolle
gefundenen an nobia ziegen heißen die
und nächstes jahr kann ich die auch
denken lassen dann sind die alt genug
und dann zum ersten mal merken und ich
bin mega gespannt darauf und ich freue
mich richtig ab dass wir wie überhaupt
gefunden haben vor allem auch die eine
gefleckte gefleckte angelogen gar nicht
so häufig da musste ich wirklich lange
nach suchen aber wir haben sie gefunden
und dann haben wir auch noch eine ganz
tolle neue milchziegen die heißt lupinen
und dies supersüß die wurde jetzt auch
gerade gedeckt das heißt ungefähr anfang
april können wenn es auch nachwuchs
freuen wenn alles geklappt hat es immer
super schön wenn die zyklen auf die welt
kommen und wenn man wieder anfangen kann
zu merken also im moment melden bin
nicht um das fehlt mir schon es ist
total komisch wieder im laden gehen zu
müssen nun ziegenkäse zu kaufen der ist
auch so extrem teuer wenn man hinten
laden kauft und wenn du eine ziege zu
hause hält wenn du jeden tag frischkäse
machst oder auch alle drei tage man kann
die milch aufbewahren und dann daraus
frischkäse machen dann hast du einfach
den ganzen topf voll und ich konnte die
eigentlich viel also ich bezahlung für
100 euro für heu im jahr
und dann noch ein bisschen
tierarztkosten und das war's also haben
jetzt im moment 15 und dann ab april ein
paar mehr und wenn die kleinen eben auf
die welt kommen und da freue ich mich
auch schon extrem drauf weil es gibt
fast nichts was so niedlich ist wie
kleine verschworene ziegler was ich auch
super schön fand war die zeit mit euch
also es macht mir super viel spaß die
videos zu erstellen ich finde es so
schön eure kommentare zu lesen eure
lieben nachrichten ich hoffe ihr seid
mir nicht böse dass ich nicht auf alles
antworten kann weil es ist einfach viel
zu viel
ich freue mich über alles was ich lese
also außer über die gemeinden sachen da
kommen auch manchmal gemeine sachen da
habe ich mich schon ein dickes fell
zugelegt aber ich freue mich über die
allermeisten nachrichten ungemein und
ich würde an die führung zurück
schreiben aber das klappt einfach nicht
ich glaube selbst wenn ich den ganzen
tag am computer sitzen und kommentare
und e mails beantworten würde würde ich
nicht hinkommen und ich will ja auch
noch raus gehen und mal ein paar andere
sachen machen also ich hoffe ihr seid
mir nicht böse und ich bin euch auf
jeden fall richtig richtig dankbar
übrigens in dem sinne dass gewinnspiel
vom youtube adventskalender läuft noch
mehr also schaut auf jeden fall mal vom
bike packt den link auch in die video
beschreibung weil da könnt ihr dieses
mal noch gewinnen das ist ja dazu da
gewesen um mal danke zu sagen und euch
was zurückzugeben und genauso nicht nur
hier auf youtube sondern ganz viele von
euch sind ja auch im gemüsegarten
staaten kurs mit dabei und auch in
meinem haltbarmachen der ernte kurs und
ja hammer ich bin super stolz auf euch
ist beim ganztag des jahres macht so
viel spaß zu beobachten wie aus einem
stück wiese das wohl jemand überhaupt
keine ahnung vom gärtnern hat dann ein
wunderschöner gemüsegarten entsteht und
am ende richtig dicke ernte und danke
für die ganzen fotos die uns immerzu
schickt ich bin hin und weg davon was
ihr alles schafft und super stolz und
ich freue mich ganz arg über jeden der
im kurs mit dabei ist weil es einfach
die coolste sache auf der welt macht
einfach richtig kritik spaß da jetzt
kommen wir aber zu einer blöden
geschichte einer richtig blöde
geschichte die mir die erste hälfte des
jahres richtig sorgen bereitet hat
eigentlich hatte schon letztes jahr
angefangen dass irgendwer angefangen hat
meine elektrozäune abzubauen bei den
siegen am anfang ich mir da noch nicht
so viel bei gedacht da dachte ich da ist
irgendwer der ein bisschen stänkern will
oder irgendwelche jugendlichen ja mal
teilweise einfach die kosten von den
elektrozäunen rausgezogen weggezogen und
die ziegen sind überall rumgelaufen den
elektrokasten umgeschmissen
da war irgendwie sowas und es war
natürlich tief weil ich gebe mich und
alle mühe meinen schach zu halten und
davon abzuhalten das sie abhauen und
dagegen kann ich dann aber nicht
vorgehen weil ich ja nicht den ganzen
tag da benutzer zu gucken dass da
niemand den zaun auf macht dann hat im
sommer auf einmal das telefon geklingelt
und da war eine ganz aufgeregte frau
dran und hat erzählt dass bei unseren
siegen ein riesengroßes feuerwehren und
dann sind wieder ganz schnell hin die
feuerwehr es schon war schon auf dem weg
ist an uns vorbei war schon vor uns dann
beim brand hat unser heuballen gebrannt
der wurde angezündet das war so ein
riesen vorjahr dass die feuerwehr über
eine halbe stunde damit beschäftigt war
den zu löschen mit sechs leuten oder
acht leuten es waren riesensache und
danach war nichts mehr übrig von dem
heuballen die haben gesagt das war
brandstiftung dann ging es weiter dass
knüppel in meinem stall lagen also
richtig dicke knüppel die ziegen da
unmöglich reingetragen haben können die
ziegen man ganz schreckhaft und ich
wusste irgendwer macht er die ganze zeit
richtige
ich wusste nicht wer und ich hatte
teilweise echt angst da hinzugehen weil
es war einfach gruselig hatte totale
angst um meine ziegen und dann genau
eine woche nach dem brand lag eine ziege
tod auf der weide ohne dass man erkennen
konnte woran sie gestorben sein sollte
das war total krass ich ziehe meinen
siegen immer die fälle abwenden die
sterben weil ich die behalten möchte und
das irgendwie schön finde wenn man
immerhin noch ein andenken davon hat und
als ich das fell abgezogen habt da habe
ich gesehen dass von ihrem gesicht an
bis runter über den hals bis zur
schulter sie ganz viele hämatome hatte
und ja ich gehe davon aus dass jemand
diese ziele auf der weide getötet hat
und ist so heftig also das war alles
andere war noch keine ahnung vielleicht
irgendwelche dummen jungen streich
aber wer so was macht der ist richtig
krank und ich habe auch anzeige
erstattet bei der polizei und die haben
da sind da immer nachts fahren die da
streife und passen auf und wir haben
bild kameras aufgehängt aber ich hatte
teilweise richtig schiss dahin zu gehen
und ich hatte so angst um meine ziegen
und es war ganz ganz ganz furchtbar
irgendwann im sommer hat es einfach
aufgehört da ist nichts mehr gewesen es
war dann noch ein paarmal der kasten
umgeschmissen und diese kleine sachen
und irgendwann hat es einfach aufgehört
und ich habe auch ehrlich gesagt lange
gedacht dass ich darüber kein video
machen möchte weil ich dieser person
keine plattform bieten möchte und ist
einfach richtig richtig krank ist ja
aber jetzt ist es wieder gut es ist
total schade um die ziege entschuldigt
bitte die audioqualität ich habe gerade
nicht die beste kamera dabei aber ich
wollte euch noch erzählen für diejenigen
von euch die meinen zielen kauf video im
frühjahr gesehen haben
da habe ich ja diese fahrzeuge gekauft
zusammen mit ihrer mama und ihre mama
war diejenige die leider getötet wurde
auf der weide da war sie noch ganz ganz
klein immer gerade so groß genug
wiederum trieb infineon sie war gerade
so groß genug dass sie alleine
durchkommen konnte aber das war total
traurig und ich hab euch ja damals
nachnamen für das zicklein gefragt die
mutter hieß cassia und deswegen habe ich
es nach seiner mutter genannt also das
ist katja die zweit und eigentlich
wollte ich sie verkaufen weil ich nicht
alle ziegen behalten kann aber irgendwie
habe ich es nicht übers herz gebracht
nachdem ihre mama dann von uns gegangen
ist werden einfach super froh dass es
jetzt vorbei ist nicht ganz so
dramatisch aber doch irgendwie auch noch
wahr dass ich habe euch ja mal erzählt
die am weihnachtsbaum im garten und
walnüsse sind ziemlich egoistische
pflanzen die unterdrücken möglichst alle
anderen pflanzen in ihrer umgebung damit
sie alle nährstoffe und alles was er
selber haben können also am besten beete
immer ganz weit von walnüssen entfernt
anlegen das war nur hier nicht möglich
weil der einstige streifen dennoch frei
war war direkt unter einer walnuss und
wir wussten dass es probleme geben würde
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass es so krass
ist also wir haben direkt unter der wahl
muss gleich zwei hochbeete hingebaut
damit da die erde ausgetauscht ist und
die pflanzen da noch mal nicht
verwahrloster erde wachsen können aber
direkt neben den beiden gebieten sind
zwei beete auf den letztes jahr schon
kaum was gewachsen ist
weil ich hatte die beobachtung gemacht
dass kohl damit eigentlich ganz gut
zurecht kommt mit der walnuss weil wir
genau daneben richtig dicke kohlköpfe
hatten und dann haben wir die eben
bisschen weiter näher an die walnuss
gepflanzt dieses jahr wieder rotieren
müssen wegen der fruchtfolge und ich
dachte wenn irgendein gemüse das ab kann
dann der cool und deswegen habe ich
quasi meinen gesamten winter kohl auf
die beiden peter neben der wahllos
gepflanzt und es ist quasi fast nichts
gewachsen
es war ganz schön es ist super schade
weil wir wollen das ganze jahr über aus
unserem garten essen und ich sag ja auch
immer allen baut wintergemüse an das ist
total cool und jetzt haben wir quasi
keinen winter cool weil ihre beiden
beete weil ich genau diese beiden bete
für die wichtigsten winter kohlgemüse
ausgewählt habe also wir haben weiß grün
köpfe die sind vielleicht so hoch obwohl
die da schon ewig stehen
und normalerweise ist mein kohl richtig
richtig gut das ist sehr frustrierend es
ist gerade jetzt wenn der winter so
langsam vor der tür steht und man sonst
nicht mehr so viel ernten kann mega
frustrierend auch der lauch ich habe den
viel früher gepflanzt noch als ich ihn
normalerweise pflanze also eigentlich
sollte der richtig dick sein aber ich
glaube es gibt keine stange die dicker
ist als mein kleiner finger also daraus
werde ich auf jeden fall lernen und auf
diesem bild nichts mehr anbauen was
irgendwie wichtig wäre also wir müssen
ja eu umziehen also solange werden wir
diesen walnussbaum jetzt nicht mehr
erdulden müssten und nächstes mal werde
ich sicher gehen dass wir ganz weit weg
vermutlich in ballungsräumen unsere
beete anlegen geht ärgert mich doch
extrem also da könnt ihr auch was vom
mitnehmen also ich hoffe wenn ich euch
immer mal fehler die ich selber mache in
den videos mitteilen dass ihr das dann
auf euch übertragen könnte und dann
daraus lernen können und es einfach
besser machen könnt ja dann
hatten wir noch ein paar ungewollte
hühner und frauen besucher im frühling
die quasi die ersten beiden sätze von
allem was ich gepflanzt habe in unserem
garten komplett auseinander genommen
haben so dass ich mit der anzucht also
ich habe dann immer wieder wenn die
hühner also sind die finger von unseren
nachbarn die irgendwie immer abhauen und
in unseren garten gehen und vor allem
auch die power frauen sind so
zerstörerisch die hüllen meine ganzen
zucchini aus die becken alles weg das
ist ganz schön heftig und die hältst du
auch nicht auf die fliegen auch auf 20
meter hohe häuser von denen haben wir
ganz viel besuch im frühling und auch
leider jetzt noch mal im sommer so dass
die einige sätze einfach an einem tag
kaputt gemacht haben wissen schon ganz
schön weh ich mein wenn man sich so viel
arbeit macht die ganze jungpflanzen
anzucht und dann hast du gerade ganz
viel gepflanzt die pflanzen sind
natürlich auch klein und empfindlich und
wahrscheinlich auch besonders lecker für
tief in die gerne blätter essen dann
gehen die einmal dadurch und du findest
nichts nicht mehr wieder uns mag ist vor
allem ja ich habe dann immer versucht
neue an zuchten im haus zu machen
irgendwie sofort zu ziehen aber
irgendwas sein hat auch einfach zu spät
für viele gemüse das heißt wir haben in
manchen bereichen in den bereichen die
wir gut schützen konnten vor den hühnern
und den frauen hatten wir eigentlich
sehr gute erträge zum beispiel im
gewächshaus wurde ja nicht reinkommen
aber manche gemüse sind komplett
weggefallen zum beispiel der schicke ich
hatte euch da versprochen dass ich euch
zeige wie ich die wurzeln ein lagerist
waren einfach keine wurzeln mehr übrig
also gar keine pflanzen erst habe es
einmal geschafft dass ein paar
fläschchen aus der erde geschaut haben
aber die haben es nicht lange überlebt
im vergleich so zu den letzten garten
jahren weil dieses jahr eins der
schlechtesten garten jahre die wir
bisher hatten also nächstes jahr kann es
eigentlich nur besser werden
ich freue mich auf einen neuen staat ja
und ich freue mich darauf irgendwann
einen garten zu haben wo wir einfach
einen zaun drum umbauen können so dass
wir jegliche tiere aus sperren können
das finde ich sowieso sinnvoller wenn
die fina eigentlich frei laufen können
und man nur die gemüsebeete und die
empfindlichen sachen mit einem zaun
schützt irgendwann wird es soweit sein
mal schauen ja und dann war da noch
diese pandemie für mich war es nicht so
ein großer einschnitt weil ich sowieso
sehr wenig wegfahre dadurch dass wir die
ganzen tiere haben und den garten und
ich eigentlich zu hause am glücklichsten
bin habe ich gar nicht so sehr das
bedürfnis danach viel zu unternehmen und
viel weg zu fahren und auch eigentlich
gar nicht die kapazitäten dafür aber im
grossen ganzen war doch ein ganz schöner
mist er dieses jahr gelaufen ist oder
wer hätte das gedacht anfang januar oder
auch letztes jahr als wir die träume und
ziele für 2020 gesteckt haben das dann
so als kombi naja was ich aber toll
finde also eine positive sache hat es
immerhin es ganz viele leute angefangen
haben ihre beete anzulegen
ich glaube das lag nicht unbedingt daran
dass leute dachten auch die
lebensmittelversorgung wird
zusammenbrechen und will alles nur noch
selber anbauen
ich glaube dass das bei sehr wenigen
deutschen die motivation ist sondern
vielmehr es war super schönes wetter
viele leute waren zu hause und hatten
zeit wussten eh nichts mit sich
anzufangen und stadt den ganzen tag von
netflix abzuhängen
haben sie dann halt gedacht eigentlich
war ich doch immer schon mal beete
anlegen und mal ein bisschen gärtnern
und gemüse anbauen dann mache ich das
doch jetzt und ich waren das sehr schön
zu beobachten dass ganz viele leute zum
gärtnern gefunden haben und dass in
diesen krassen jahr trotzdem noch so was
schönes dabei herausgekommen ist und ich
hoffe ihr bleibt dabei was du gerade
dieses jahr mit dem gärtnern angefangen
hast von der pandemie dass es dir spaß
gemacht hat und dass du lust hast das
auch weiterhin zu machen wenn ich super
cool also daumen hoch für alle die
dieses jahr zum ersten mal gern da ein
großer flop war für uns natürlich auch
die nachricht dass wir umziehen müssen
ich habe eben das video von letztem jahr
gedruckt und da habe ich gesagt es wäre
gerade schon umgezogen sind und dass es
so schlimm ist
so viel liebe und energie und zeit ein
stück boden steckt und sich so mitten im
ort verbindet und dann ausziehen muss
falls ihr das video noch nicht gesehen
habt wo ich erzähle warum und so weiter
schaut gerne da oben oder unten in der
video beschreibung nach
das war natürlich ein harter rückschlag
aber mittlerweile sind wir ganz guter
dinge dass wir da raus irgendwie was
positives machen können auch wenn es
wahrscheinlich noch dauert bis wir
irgendwann was gefunden haben aber wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt erstmal auf den
umzug in die wohnung wir haben denn
jetzt eine wohnung ohne garten können
aber den garten hier noch weiter nutzten
zum glück irgendwann ziehen wir auf
unseren schüttelt raum hof oder kaufen
uns ein haus mit einem riesen garten und
dann können wir alles genauso machen wie
wir wollen ohne weihnachtsbaum oder doch
mit walnussbaum auf jeden fall aber die
kommen ganz der gemüsegarten wird fest
eingezäunt und sieben auch kämpfen des
social hub siegen am haus zu haben mich
die beste beschützen kann ihr könnt ihr
mal unten in die kommentare schreiben
sie ein jahr gelaufen ist ich würde mich
auf jeden fall sehr freuen von euch zu
hören
auch mal zuhören was ihr euch für
nächstes jahr vornimmt was sie anders
machen wollte und die freue mich total
wenn wir uns im neuen jahr wieder sehen
einen guten rutsch euch allen und macht